reason apology there's only risk of the
show for them good reason apology you
know I'm just wondering what else is
missing I'll let you know
welcome
uh
so in terms of live streaming I
understand that Ria will be joining by
Zoom
Bruce will be joining by zoom and so I'm
sharing this but he is delayed with some
issues in Wellington at the moment
and I understand that Grant is going to
be 15 minutes late
um I don't think any other apologies
thank you the other
sorry
I'll move those apologies to be accepted
because I have a second to please thank
you Tom all those in favor please say
aye against obstinians carried thank you
the other point of note is that there
are councilors here that are not members
of this committee we have had a
precedent in the past that though all
councilors present can vote
so with the committee's permission I
would suggest that all councilors be
able to vote that are present
I'll second the move
thank you
uh decorations of interest uh Navi has
raised with me that he does have a
conflict of interest
uh and that he would like to make a
statement in public excluded and then
we'll retire from the meeting
are there any other
confidence that anyone wishes to note at
this point in time Bobby just on the
issue of uh non-members voting and
that's that's new to me
and so in our recent meetings within the
last week we've had examples where
people have put their hand up to
um nominate motion or second it and
being told they can't because they're
not a member of the committee so it's a
bit new to me I'm not trying to
roadblock the process but this is a very
sensitive issue and I think if you start
opening the door to people being present
that can both are not on the committee
that opens a bit of a Pandora's Box
going along with the mayor that would be
inconsistent with our governance
statement
what we have and we need to
I don't know what we need to do to
correct it but at the moment our
government statement stayed so many of
those on the committee I'm willing to be
corrected as just as at this committee
previously we have allowed it so
it was
like I I was under the understanding it
was if the committee passes as such
a general
practice has been that if you're not on
the committee you're not entitled to
vote or move a resolution and that's
what we've been doing but whilst Mr
chair is quite correct this committee
has in the past done essentially as
councilor Cricket has suggested
um
if you are strictly adhering to standing
orders then only those members of this
committee would be able to vote
Tom
I think clearly the smarter that will
consider during PE as a matter which is
of
very general interest to all counselors
um rather than only committee members I
don't think committee members have got a
particular interest beyond the interest
that other counselors have
for that reason I I would support
um having all counselors able to vote
um
I don't feel really strongly about it
but I mean I think if we found that
um there was only a relatively small
number of us who could vote then it
really were tough to go to me and kept
mean Council to
discuss
two important issue would be to say is
about three or four people in my view
so following on from that why is this
coming to this committee and not to feel
cancer why is it not an extraordinary
meaning of council
and that would include I can't answer
that
would include everybody and deal is done
throw yourself chair this is
um this report has been raised by the
chair of risk and Assurance is this is a
been deemed a risk issuer as Associated
from that perspective so
is is that is what it is being
classified as would fit the criteria
being within the risk and Assurance
committee
um fits within the remit of that
it will end up from that perspective
from a committee side going back to
council regardless because all all
committee papers do end up going through
Council so it will go back to council
and also through your self-cheo I just
want to clarify in relation to the
voting uh that is quite right in
relation to the standard voting of any
committee is restricted to those
committee meetings and can only be
deviated from
um being voted or voted at the time to
actually change that voting for a
particular paper of those at the meeting
and that's part of the standing orders
and that has to be a motion which has
been done to actually change that for
the particular was it was that
advertised to all of our members that
they knew that if they did come along
they could vote because obviously was
that advertised that fact not not to my
knowledge that was not um because
obviously those here now know but those
who may not be here said well you know
I'm not a Committee Member why would I
come if they haven't been told
thing I feel that is uh
through yourself chair I just want to
clarify that's the decision of the chair
not through staff recommendations from
that perspective so that you can make
that um as part of the mean
they so desired okay
basically thanks Mr chair
um it seems to me we've canvassed this
issue quite well there's a motion on the
table I'm going to move but the motion
be put to be put to a vote
which which version Leslie the motion
the motion that you moved okay or the
children you moved and seconded that um
that voting be allowed to all parties
it's quite clear if the committee votes
that way then we allow that boat to be
widened
um it has happened before on this
committee I do remember that
um and I see
no reason why that motion shouldn't be
put to the vote
I think that's the easiest way to
clarify so pulling a water chip
um so that means that the current
members of the committee are the ones
that vote on whether it's widened out
correct yeah
the motion has been
sorry yeah
sorry all right sorry about
um this am I down it's not there
physically I can't partake in the vote
understanding orders you can vote
the motion is that they're all cut all
members present all councilors
are able to vote
so just before that Alex couldn't handle
the view
it's fine okay thank you sorry thank you
though
it's always been moved from the second
that I'll put the motion all those in
favor please sir
say hi
against uh I'm just abstaining can I buy
that that recorded I'm not happy with
this and I'll be following it up
thanks
uh could I please have uh I'll move from
the chair that we now move to public
excluded that's a second of please
second thank you Leslie if you say I hi
thank you